where's dum in Star Wars we got to talk
about this
Star Wars Attack of the Clones opened
yesterday people are saying this may
very well smash box-office records by
the end of this weekend it could be the
biggest movie opening of all time the
anticipation for this new Star Wars
movie has been intense and you probably
read about this it's been in all the
papers fans lined up weeks in advance to
wait for the opening these are very
devoted people they camped out they
waited so earlier this week before the
movie opened we thought it would be a
good idea to send a responsible
correspondent check out the scene and
see what's going on we bring you the
news so so we sent triumph the insult
comic dog
we sent triumphs I'm gonna start wearing
bow ties for when this happened
we sent triumph the insult comic dog to
the Ziegfeld Theatre right here in New
York City and we had him check out the
line of die-hard Star Wars fans here
ladies and gentlemen is his report yes
it's premiere night here for Attack of
the Clones
but outside the Ziegfeld Theatre is the
real show return of the dorks thousands
of 35 year old men waiting days even
months for just a taste of George
Lucas's table straps lonely men who have
never had sex not even with a Catholic
priest
[Music]
[Applause]
supposed to be a Jedi you're a Jedi
Knight yes and what are the principles
of the Jedi Knight always defend truth
and justice throughout the galaxy and to
eat a lot of peanut M&Ms
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no it's good about these custom folks
take a look he has the ability he can
crap his pants and no one will know the
one is thinking and rousing games of
Star Wars Stratego this is risk very
exciting this game is normally played
indoors by 12 year olds
this is a nice break for you you're
getting away from the drudgery of your
normal mundane life spent playing
Stratego at home unbelievable look among
the Nerds I found an actual girl here is
not not too shabby around here honey the
male-female ratio here I mean you've got
your veritable pick of the litter you
can choose from all of all kinds of guys
who have no idea how to please you
[Applause]
she said pretty much to stand up to this
challenge stand up to this right and I'm
scooping lassie standing in line here
all this time waiting for the show how
do you explain this to your imaginary
girlfriend look at this one some kind of
super nerd
Ryobi wanna back off
I don't deal with lesser life points you
don't deal with lesser life-forms you
must be a lonely guy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at you how are you cutie what
parent forced you to do this that's
adorable that's really very very cute
I'll be right over here
it's very very cute got a little future
no future no future tonight
when is he due June 27 six weeks Wow
that's the last time you'll ever see
female genitalia
[Applause]
repeating your head snake and/or garage
look at this look at this it's a geek
from another dimension
don't you forget to finish your
filet-o-fish Dragon Master just to pay
your respects with the Jedi hello you
know what you are one out
you are one uninformed hound you know
that it's called reality parent looking
for a Jedi to challenge the nerd from
Lord of the Rings your superiors that
late not even even decided to let you
out today seriously yes have you ever
talked to a woman without having to give
your credit card number
take this found quite an imagination
this movie is a little far-fetched what
do you guys think
and we now let's talk about spoilers
here i I've got some spoilers
what's your explainer mr. spoiler you
will die alone
favorite impersonation from The Empire
Strikes Back hit you are failed me for
the last time Admiral captain Piett yes
my lord
make ready the fleet and deploy it out
so that nothing gets off the system
that's perfect but you're not breathing
heavily now imagine you've just run ten
feet very exciting Darth Vader himself
is here all the other nerds tremble in
his presence
[Applause]
[Music]
it will be my test box that helps me the
brain so this is to help you breathe yes
and which of these give these buttons
calls your parents to pick you out
[Applause]
[Music]
thus our troopers talk like sixties
robots I was here by Felix
you know something you would look really
good with some sauerkraut and some
mustard are you a Korean guy under there
[Applause]
we being yourself 3:00 p.m. your son hi
oh my god that was a close one
actual Star Wars nerd can I ask a
question about the couple were they
spending their honeymoon which which are
key the groom has kissed the bride after
years of practicing on his system you
are Tom and now the nerves are
congregating for the ceremonial banging
of the plastic toys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm your father
okay you guys ready for some trivia
here's the first question what substance
was Han Solo frozen in no no I'm sorry
I'm very sorry the correct answer is who
gives it pretty nerds
let's enjoy
all right now they're asking to be
pulled back up guys
dear friends our work here is over we
have enjoyed our stay but the forces of
reality and the demands of a normal sex
life compel us to depart maybe for me
with you for me
all right everybody we'll take a break
we come back